vamos a nuestra revista de prensa Como
cada mañana con Rosa Pérez más de Ur
Rosa Buenos días para usted Buenos días
Ángela el tema de hoy no me gusta que lo
tengamos que tocar pero por favor
hagamos este repaso profundo sobre los
terremotos de Turquía y Siria que llenan
las portadas internacionales vamos a
empezar por las de Estados Unidos o con
el New York Times exactamente y vamos a
hacer un recorrido por las portadas en
papel que a pesar de que cada vez haya
menos gente no que lee los periódicos en
papel verlas analizarlas sirve para ver
cuando sobre todo un tema ocupa el foco
mediático en distintos lugares del mundo
no y como bien decías el New York Times
en portada titula una región cicatrizada
herida excava en busca de supervivientes
los sirios que viven entre las ruinas de
la guerra devastados por la nueva crisis
el Wall Street journal también este
periódico de Nueva York el número de
Muertos aumenta y cerraba enviaba esta
edición a imprimir a rotativas No cuando
el número de Muertos llegaba a cuatro
mil sin embargo Lamentablemente ya
supera los y para seguir compensa
económica el financial Times titula
miles de Muertos después de que el mayor
terremoto en 84 años acudiera Siria y
Turquía
Eso es por el lado de Estados Unidos que
dicen en Europa
este medio también británico dice
terremoto gigante mata a miles de
personas mientras dormían en liberación
de Francia con siempre estos titulares
tan claros y directos dice la tragedia
dos terremotos de magnitudes magnitudes
7,8 y 7,5 afectaron a Siria y Turquía
causando miles de víctimas el país se
señala devastación ankarada lanza una
petición de ayuda internacional mientras
en Siria en guerra civil desde hace 11
años los temblores azotan sobre todo el
territorio Rebelde jurríate este
periódico Turco dice Rendirse ante el
desastre y Ángela particularmente nos
hemos querido fijar y dedicar un gráfico
en especial a la prensa italiana porque
hemos querido destacar como tres de las
principales cabeceras del país coinciden
en una misma palabra y es Apocalipsis el
corriere de la cera titula los golpes o
el shock luego el Apocalipsis la
República dice la sacudida o el temblor
y Apocalipsis la estampa Apocalipsis
Turquía es que es impresionante Rosa
países latinoamericanos también han
respondido incluso enviando equipos de
ayuda hacia Turquía y hacia Siria que
dicen en los medios de comunicación Pues
bien en Brasil donde este tema no ocupa
las principales portadas también vemos
como en o globo dicen terremoto mate a
miles y de vastas ciudades en Turquía y
Siria no Y estos miles siempre porque
los medios ya no se atreven sobre todo a
enviar a rotativas una cifra exacta
cuando tal y como han señalado las
autoridades pueden encontrarse todavía
muchas víctimas mortales entre las
ruinas no a medida que se que vayan
avanzando estas labores de búsqueda la
misma imagen y un titular parecido en la
fuera de são Paulo y en el estado de Sao
Paulo o también en La Crónica de hoy en
México o el tiempo de aquí de Colombia
Ángela le dedica el editorial y entre
otras cosas se cita el testimonio de una
colombiana que se encontraba en ankara y
que dice los edificios
se tambaleaban se me hacían como hamacas
mire al yacira en medio de todo esto
está haciendo una cobertura especial que
vale la pena revisar Sí exactamente les
alentamos en la medida de lo posible a
ver al jazzira porque está haciendo un
especial a muy a fondo sobre la
situación con las últimas
actualizaciones y encontramos también a
testigos no de esta tragedia y
destacable la forma en que la gente
intenta poner palabras a lo vivido como
esta colombiana que decía que los
edificios se mecían Como hamacas en al
jazzira encontramos a lip en it lip en
esta ciudad Siria a un hombre mua más de
60 años un refugiado interno de Siria
originario de OMS que dice nuestra casa
se movía como las olas del mar mientras
salíamos empezó a derrumbar Rosa en unos
minutos vamos a tener un invitado que
nos va a hablar desde la situación del
terreno en Siria y Turquía antes vamos a
hacer una pausa en este tema para que
usted nos hable un poco del chat yept
rápidamente exactamente porque también
no se abordará en este en este programa
más adelante y simplemente queríamos
destacar dos periodistas que han hecho
entrevistas con el propio chat no para
intentar averiguar Cómo es la
interacción a con esta máquina que ha
causado tanto impacto a nivel mundial
empezamos por la entrevista de Dalia
Aventura para la bbc que explica nuestro
primer encuentro con el chat fue
absolutamente casual escuché parte de
una conversación sobre alguien que
preguntó cómo hacía para levantar para
conquistar a más chicas y le
respondieron que antes que nada las
mujeres no eran un objeto que se
levantaba Así que lo primero que le
recomendaba era cambiar su manera de
pensar y de referirse a las mujeres
inmediatamente dice quise saber quién
había dicho esto y la respuesta fue el
chat gpt entonces entre las distintas
preguntas que la periodista Dalia
Aventura le plantea a la máquina está
Así que vas a reemplazar a los humanos y
él dice la máquina no como máquina no
tengo deseos ni motivaciones personales
no soy capaz de apoderarme de la
humanidad mis capacidades se limitan a
la información en la que he sido
entrenado y las tareas específicas que
he sido programado para realizar no Y en
este mismo sentido en el que entendamos
No que al final la Inteligencia
artificial se nutre de la información
que le proporcionamos el entrenamiento
que le damos también para terminar
Carlos del Castillo en el diario punto
es escribe en sus respuestas a este
medio asistan no también el chat gpt
llega a reconocer que es una
Inteligencia artificial opaca ya que es
incapaz de revelar cómo están
configuradas sus bases de datos se trata
de un aspecto clave de estos sistemas
algorítmicos que vestidos de una
aparente neutralidad matemática pueden
reproducir el machismo racismo o
clasismo presente en la documentación
que ha sido usada para entrenar o los
mismos sesgos de sus programadores Así
mismo lo afirma la máquina de esto vamos
a hablar también más adelante con
nuestro segundo invitado del día gracias
a usted Muchas gracias Ángela